- When is dancing a protest?
- When it's Bomba.
(drums playing)
- Bomba is a traditional
genre of music and dance
from Puerto Rico
and has made an appearance
at many recent Black
Lives Matter protests.
- In Bomba, dancing and protests
are inextricably linked.
Surprised?
Once you understand the
music, it makes perfect sense.
(upbeat music)
- So now that we know
Bomba's influence today,
let's talk about where it came from.
And to do that,
we have to go back about 400 years.
Last year our friends from,
If Cities Could Dance,
traveled to Puerto Rico
and filmed this footage for
their episode on Bomba dancing.
Make sure you check out that
episode on their channel.
(drums playing)
- Bomba was developed in the 16th century
by enslaved Africans in Puerto Rico
enslaved communities would gather
to make music using rhythms and
dance to express themselves.
They told stories, shared
news, communicated revolts
and connected with each other.
This process of gathering through Bomba
was known as Bambula, a
practice of re- remembrance.
Re-remembering where you came from
and your own sense of humanity.
In other words,
they created culture and
affirmed their humanity
and that is a powerful form of resistance.
How would you describe Bomba
to people who haven't heard it before?
or who haven't heard of it even?
- Well Bomba is the oldest
genre of Puerto Rico
tracing back to our African roots,
it tells the story of our ancestors.
It is meant for healing.
It is a time-traveling genre
and it's Black music.
- Yes.
Bomb's roots largely come from Africa
but like so much of Latinx culture,
it's a blending of
elements from many regions.
While most Bomba songs are in Spanish.
Some have words and
phrases in other languages
including Haitian Creole and Kikongo.
(drums playing)
The use of long ruffled
skirts as Bomba costumes
also shows incorporation
of Spanish influences
in Bomba today.
(drums playing)
The Taino where the
indigenous people of Boriken,
their name for the Island
that is now Puerto Rico.
That's also the reason many Puerto Rican's
prefer the term Boricua.
Taino influence in Bomba
shows up in terms like, Batey,
which refers to the dance space.
(drums playing)
- The use of a single gourd based maraca
also shows Taino influence.
The maraca is used to keep time
and it's often played by the singer.
Cuas are sticks, often played
against the side of a Barril
or the drum used for Bomba.
Can you talk about the significance
of the Barril or the drum in Bomba
and like why this specific drum is used?
- The Barril, I would say in Spanish
but in English, its barrel.
- [LA Buckner] Barrel.
- It's made out of a barrel.
But its made out of,
a rum barrel, tea barrel, whiskey barrels.
Like whatever type of
barrel you can think of,
it's made from that.
That's what we had when
those ensalved Africans came..
- Ancestors.
- Came from the motherland
into the Caribbean.
- Yeah.
- And then they needed their resource
and because they had all these rhythms
so they used the resources that they had
and what we use on, when
it comes to the skin,
it's goat skin.
- [LA Buckner] Yes.
- So now we're talking
about a type of drum
that relates to the Djembe family.
- Yes.
- [Mateo Gonzalez] Well,
all those African based..
- Absolutely
- [Mateo Gonzalez] Drums.
- So what makes the
rhythms of Bomba, Bomba?
First, there are two types of Bomba drums.
The lead drummer is known
as the Subidor or Primo
and plays a higher pitched Barril.
The other drummers play a Buleador
and keep a steady rhythm called a buleo.
(drums playing)
While that steady rhythm is going,
a dancer enters the
Batey, by doing a Paseo,
walking around in a circle
to mark their space,
ending with a salute to the Primo.
One of the most surprising
things about Bomba
is that the lead drummers
job, is actually to follow.
As the dancer begins to dance,
the Primo follows their
movements with the drum,
striking to the rhythm
of the dancers steps.
It's a conversation.
Dancers use common dance
moves and improvisations
to express their thoughts and emotions.
The drummer watches closely,
anticipating, following and giving voice
to their movements with the drum.
(drums playing)
For the enslaved people
who created the music form,
Bomba was one of the
only vehicles they had
to express themselves
freely and to feel powerful.
Reclaiming their sense of
humanity and self determination
was an act of resistance.
(singing in foreign language)
Bomba has a collection
of rhythmic patterns
each used for different
purposes or emotions.
For example,
Sica, means the act of rising up.
(drums playing)
Cuembe is to restore balance.
Seis Corrido is a faster rhythm,
traditionally played in Loiza.
(drums playing)
Yuba is good for releasing
negative emotions
like sadness and anger.
It refers to an ancestral ritual
of cleansing space and self.
You can feel that in the heaviness
of the last beat in the pattern.
(drums playing)
I know Sica, Cuembe,
Seis Corrido and Yuba.
What was the other one you said?
- Holande.
Just hearing it, holande.
- Is influenced by the Dutch.
- Okay.
- The way we dance Holande
is mimicking the slave owners,
how they dance.
- Wow!
- So how we dance Holande
is influenced by them.
(drums playing)
- Bomba lyrics are simple
and reflect daily life.
Singers also take influence
from the drumming and the dancing
that they see in front of them.
Generally, the lead singer
will start singing a short chorus.
The chorus is repeated by others
as lead singer adds
improvised versus in between.
(singing in foreign language)
The chorus the people,
the community responds.
(singing in foreign language)
And then I start storytelling.
And so I start talking.
So there are some songs
that are written, right?
But there's also this beautiful
aspect of singing Bomba
where you are just in the zone.
You're there.
- Mhm.
- We got so many beautiful
Bomba songs everywhere
that are traditional, that are written.
We also have space to improvise.
- That call response format
is another example of African
influence in Bomba music.
It's also one reason
that there's always a place
for everyone at a Bombazo
and audience members
are often participants.
(drums playing)
Throughout the Puerto Rican diaspora,
there are families, schools,
and performance groups
keeping Bomba alive
and passing the art form
to new generations today.
Today, people who practice
Bomba continue to use it
as a platform for awareness,
resistance and pride.
Bomba is much more than a dance or music.
It's a way of life.
- Talk about the
significance of Bomba to you.
- Bomba is life.
- Mhm.
- Because especially I was
raised in this tradition.
You know, I was raised to just one person.
Definitely influenced by my grandfather.
But everybody knows him as, Benny.
Unfortunately, I just lost
him a week and a half ago.
- Oh, I'm sorry to hear that bro.
- Yeah, thank you.
- And the Cepeda Family of of San Juan,
one of Puerto Rico's most
famous Bomba families.
The music has been passed
down for eight generations
and the Cepeda's are known
for having created the first Bomba school.
(drums playing)
(singing in foreign language)
In recent years,
Bomba has been a balm for those suffering
from the aftermath of Hurricane Maria.
After the storm, people
gathered to dance Bomba
as a way to express their
feelings of pain and loss
and come together as a community.
(drums playing)
And now Bomba is an integral part
of Black Lives Matter movements
throughout the Puerto Rican diaspora.
(drums playing)
- Loiza is a center of
Afro-Boricua culture on the Island.
After the murder of George Floyd,
Loiza was one of the first
Latin American communities
to organize demonstrations.
Bomba and Plena were central
to their vigils and protests.
(drums playing)
- Why do you think Bomba
has been so present in Black
Lives Matter movements lately?
Is it that authenticity?
That community?
I feel like there's so much.
- The reason why we're out here
protesting of Black Lives Matter
is because we are reclaiming our spaces.
You know, when we step back,
when we say black
there's our Afro Latinos, Afro Latinas.
There's so much to what Black means.
This is the music that
existed when we were oppressed
and we're still oppressed.
So this is a way that we
need to stop that oppression
and to bring new ways of thinking.
- Mhm.
- We're authentically
us, beautiful in our skin
no matter the color of our skin.
But when we bring Bomba,
we're talking about Black roots.
- Whether traditional or
fused with other styles,
Bomba is a reclaiming of
Puerto Rican's African heritage
and a way of countering racism
and other injustices in their
communities and in the world.
What aspect of Bomba do you
find the most interesting
or what aspect of Bomba music
do you respect the most?
- I feel like I came very
much into my black identity
later than most of my peers,
especially being Puerto Rican
and you know, Bomba's Puerto Rican,
but there's a lot of
anti-blackness everywhere.
Especially though in Latino cultures
and I feel like people
don't think about it.
But you know, when you think Puerto Rican,
you think J.Lo,
you think Marc Anthony,
you think like, you know..
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- First of all, I'm black,
look at me in black,
but also (laughing loudly)
like this is my culture and
I found it through music.
And so it's like an archive, you know?
- Yeah, yeah.
Absolutely.
- And I think it's so cool.
It felt kinda like when you
do one of those ancestry tests
and you're like, wow, you know,
it felt kinda like that for me.
It's just so illuminating
that there are so many people
that share these stories
and share these histories.
And like, you know,
that is part of what has
made me the person that I am.
And that's like my,
really my history.
(drums playing)
(signing in foreign language)
- Sound Field finally has a Patreon
where you can support us.
Get behind the scenes concert footage
and early access to every new episode.
Link in the description.
(drums playing)